روسيا تتمكن من صد ما وصفته باخطر توغل في
اراضيها منذ بدء الحرب في اوكرانيا وتعلن
اخراج المجموعات المسلحه من روسيا نتحدث
هنا عن مقاطعه
الروسيه الحدوديه مع اوكرانيا اليها دخلت
مجموعه مسلحه من اوكرانيا واصابت نقاط
تفتيش على الحدود بنيران الدبابات وايضا
المسيرات ودخلت الى عمق المقاطعه ما يسمى
بفيلق حريه روسيا اعلن عبر صفحات على
وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي مسؤوليته عن
الهجوم وسيطرته على قرى كوزينكا
حدوديه روسيه لاعطاء اكياف ولقد ضغط في اي
محادثات قادمه مع موسكو الوثائق ذكرت ان
اوكرانيا خططت لتنظيم عمليات تسلل تسلل
للمقاتلين هم متطوعين الى مقاطعه
للسيطره على مدن روسيه واعلان جمهوريات
مستقله فيها طبعا على غرار مناطق شرق
اوكرانيا واشارت الوثائق ايضا الى ان
اوكرانيا تخطط لتشكيل مكونا عسكري اكبر
يعتمد على متطوعين لاحداث وفتح جبهه حرب
اهليه في روسيا
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات